Nothing prepares you for what the border between Israel and the West Bank can look like. In the town of [UNINTELLIGIBLE] on the Israeli side, there's a bedroom community that looks like it was airlifted from Scottsdale, Arizona. Rows of houses with white stucco walls and red roofs and yards where you could see plastic slides and other kids' toys. And then a perfectly paved street, and then on the other side of the street, a wire fence and some no man's land, then an electrified fence, then more no man's land, and then a tall, concrete wall with sentry posts and armed Israeli soldiers.
没有任何事物能让你为以色列和西岸之间可能呈现的景象做好准备。在以色列一侧的[听不清]镇上，有一个居民社区，看起来像是从亚利桑那州的斯科茨代尔空运过来的。一排排带有白色灰泥墙和红色屋顶的房子，院子里可以看到塑料滑梯和其他孩子的玩具。然后是一条铺设完美的街道，街道对面是一道铁丝网和一些无人区，接着是一道通电的围栏，再往后是更多的无人区，最后是一堵高高的混凝土墙，上面有哨所和全副武装的以色列士兵。
An 18 year old who lives on the street told me that even here, where she sees the barricades that protect her every day, she tries to ignore what's on the other side.
一位住在街上的18岁女孩告诉我，即使在这里，她每天都能看到保护她的路障，但她还是试图忽略另一边的情况。
I don't think I think about it very much of it. When I hear things in the news, yeah, it worries me and all that. But I live my life.
我觉得我不太想这些。当我从新闻里听到这些消息时，是的，这确实让我担心。但我还是过着我的生活。
What's the point of thinking about it? There's a bumper sticker a Tel Aviv advertising writer made up a few months after the current wave of violence began in Israel.
想这些有什么意义呢？在以色列当前的暴力浪潮开始几个月后，一位特拉维夫的广告撰稿人编出了一句汽车保险杠贴纸上的标语。
It says [SPEAKING HEBREW].
上面写着[希伯来语]。
Which has the same sad double meaning in Hebrew that it does in English. Roughly, give it to them, and there will be peace in Israel. That is, give up the Territories to the Palestinians and there will be peace in Israel. And then also--
它在希伯来语中有着和在英语中一样悲伤的双重含义。粗略地说，就是“给他们，以色列就会有和平”。也就是说，把领土交给巴勒斯坦人，以色列就会有和平。还有——
The other meaning, give them back is like, show them that we're the best, so we're stronger.
另一种含义，“还击他们”，就像是说，向他们展示我们是最棒的，我们更强大。
Like, we'll give it to them.
就像是，我们会把它给他们。
Well, yes. Hit them back.
嗯，是的。反击他们。
That's a complete contradiction. Either you give it back or you hit them back.
这完全是自相矛盾的。要么你把它交还，要么你反击他们。
It is, it is. But we suffer from some kind of schizophrenia, I think, nowadays.
确实是。但我认为，我们现在患上了一种精神分裂症。
And it's not just Israelis who are feeling schizophrenic nowadays. Sitting in a cafe in Ramallah, Rula Hamadani goes back and forth, trying to make sense of what to feel about the collapse of the peace process.
如今感到精神分裂的不仅仅是以色列人。坐在拉马拉的一家咖啡馆里，鲁拉·哈马达尼（Rula Hamadani）反复思索，试图理清对于和平进程崩溃的感受。
I never thought Oslo was right. And then I decided, like, come on, Rula, it's a chance to dream. It's not good enough, but it might work.
我从未认为《奥斯陆协议》是正确的。后来我决定，算了吧，鲁拉，这是一个梦想的机会。虽然不够好，但可能会奏效。
When I was younger, I never met an Israeli in my life. I never had an Israeli friend. But it's between the two intifadas, like, I had to leave Israeli friends. I don't know. The peace process gave us something, but it seems the peace process also took back everything. Took back the friends, took back, like, the good days they had together. And it's gone.
我年轻的时候，这辈子从没见过以色列人。我从没有过以色列朋友。但在两次起义之间，我不得不离开以色列朋友。我不知道。和平进程给了我们一些东西，但看起来和平进程也收回了一切。收回了朋友，收回了我们曾共同拥有的美好时光。一切都消失了。
Tom Segev, an Israeli journalist and historian, says people are confused because for nearly a decade, Israelis, at least, thought there would be peace. Israelis thought this more than Palestinians. And then peace evaporated. And their confusion even shows up in the polls. Their entries are completely contradictory.
以色列记者兼历史学家汤姆·塞格夫（Tom Segev）说，人们感到困惑是因为在近十年里，至少以色列人认为会有和平。以色列人比巴勒斯坦人更坚信这一点。然后和平蒸发了。他们的困惑甚至体现在民意调查中。他们的回答完全是自相矛盾的。
You ask people, do you support the establishment of a Palestinian state? Yes, I do. Do you support the reoccupation of the West Bank? Yes, I do. Do you support the dismantlement of the settlements? Yes, I do that support that also. So this is very strange situation where Israel doesn't know what to do.
你问人们，你支持建立巴勒斯坦国吗？是的，我支持。你支持重新占领西岸吗？是的，我支持。你支持拆除定居点吗？是的，我也支持。所以这是一个非常奇怪的局面，以色列不知道该怎么做。
We are doing things which don't make much sense. We let a 16 year old suicide bomber dictate the whole agenda of the Middle East. He blows himself up in Tel Aviv, we go and occupy Ramallah. Is it good for us to occupy Ramallah? It's probably not. But we do it, because what else should we do?
我们正在做的事情并没有多大意义。我们让一个16岁的自杀式炸弹袭击者左右了整个中东的议程。他在特拉维夫炸死了自己，我们就去占领拉马拉。占领拉马拉对我们有好处吗？可能没有。但我们还是做了，因为我们还能做什么呢？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories from Israel and the West Bank. We all hear the ongoing, never-ending news reports from the region, which just seem to get worse and worse, and we wanted to take a moment and step back. It's been nearly two years since the peace process collapsed-- two years in which each side has done terrible things together. And we wanted to understand what that's done to people, and if anybody's feeling any hope.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。在今天的节目中，我们将讲述来自以色列和西岸的故事。我们都听到了该地区持续不断、没完没了的新闻报道，这些报道似乎变得越来越糟糕，我们想花点时间退后一步审视一下。和平进程崩溃已经快两年了——在这两年里，双方都共同做了可怕的事情。我们想了解这对人们造成了什么影响，以及是否还有人感到怀有希望。
I was in Israel with two of our regular contributors, Nancy Updike and Adam Davidson. Nancy did our stories from the West Bank. Adam and I traveled around Israel. And we begin our program with Nancy.
我和我们节目的两位常驻撰稿人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）在以色列。南希负责西岸的故事，亚当和我则在以色列各地旅行。我们从南希的报道开始我们的节目。
Act One. Life Indoors. Here's Nancy's first report.
第一幕：室内生活。这是南希的第一篇报道。
Curfew is how Palestinians live now. The Israeli army is in the streets, and if you go outside, day or night, you can be shot. Indoors it's just boring, and debilitating in a way I hadn't expected.
宵禁是巴勒斯坦人现在的生活方式。以色列军队在街上，如果你白天或晚上外出，可能会被枪击。在室内只会感到无聊，而且以一种我没预料到的方式变得虚弱。
In the middle of a Tuesday afternoon in Ramallah, I needed to get off the street, and ended up at a TV studio. There were mattresses all over the floor, maybe 10 people living there. Because of curfew, they couldn't get home. We were all stuck. Everyone sat around in the kitchen smoking, and then at some point, one of the guys asked me, "You want to watch Riverdance?" I wasn't sure I'd heard right.
在一个周二的下午，在拉马拉，我需要离开街道，最后走进了一家电视台。地板上到处都是床垫，大概有10个人住在这里。因为宵禁，他们无法回家。我们都被困住了。每个人都坐在厨房里抽烟，这时，其中一个人问我：“你想看《大河之舞》（Riverdance）吗？”我不确定我听得对不对。
--the land. They carry us over the ocean in dance and song.
——这片土地。他们在舞蹈和歌声中载着我们越过海洋。
For half an hour, we watched Riverdance. Outside, the streets were empty and silent. No cars, no people. It looked like the carcass of a city.
半小时里，我们看了《大河之舞》。外面，街道空荡寂静。没有车，没有人。它看起来像是一座城市的残骸。
I'd come into Ramallah that morning from Jerusalem, a normal, bustling city, and it was like leaving earth and stepping onto a planet where gravity was working differently. Everyone was moving very slowly. I could feel my energy and purposefulness draining out of me. There is nowhere to go and no way to get there.
那天早上我是从耶路撒冷进到拉马拉的，那是一个正常、熙熙攘攘的城市，而这里就像是离开了地球，踏上了一个重力运作方式不同的星球。每个人都在缓慢地移动。我能感觉到我的精力和目标感正在从我身上流失。没有地方可去，也没有办法到达那里。
Qasem Ali runs the television production company where I ended up.
卡西姆·阿里（Qasem Ali）经营着我最终到达的那家电视制作公司。
For ten days I have been in these offices. Actually doing nothing. Watching television. And even the newspaper, you don't get it. A little bit degrading.
十天来，我一直待在这些办公室里。其实什么也没做。看电视。连报纸都拿不到。有点丢人。
Myself, I'm, just like now, I'm feeling [? withdrawing. ?] Spending so much time in the room by myself, doing nothing. You are not in the mood even to read. You don't want to talk to people. And you don't want, you know, to socialize.
就我而言，就像现在，我感觉[？正在退缩。？]独自在房间里待了太久，什么都不做。你甚至没有心情去阅读。你不想和人交谈。你不想，你知道，去社交。
Qasem smoked Camel after Camel as we talked. He was handsome, with dark hair and a beard going gray. He leaned his head on his hand as he talked. He seemed exhausted.
当我们交谈时，卡西姆一支接一支地抽着骆驼牌香烟。他长得很英俊，留着深色的头发和灰白的胡须。他一边谈话，一边用手托着头。他看起来精疲力竭。
You know, first day, second day, you can adapt and do something. But then, you feel like your life is worthless, and your time is worthless. And you get to the point, like, you started hating the life. What do you want to do for tomorrrow, or after tomorrow? The days become the same. Without taste.
你知道，第一天、第二天，你可以适应并做点什么。但后来，你觉得你的生活毫无价值，你的时间也毫无价值。你会达到那种程度，就像你开始厌恶生活一样。你明天想做什么，或者后天之后呢？日子变得千篇一律。索然无味。
You know, you're fighting this kind of mood. Sometimes you are not capable of fighting it, because you don't see the signs of it. And this is how, like, really, curfew as punishment. It's collective punishment.
你知道，你是在对抗这种情绪。有时你无力对抗它，因为你看不到它的迹象。这就是宵禁作为惩罚的方式。这是集体惩罚。
This phrase, "collective punishment," was uttered by every Palestinian I talked to. I figured it was some description that had just caught on. I didn't realize until I got back that "collective punishment" is a legal term the UN uses. It means punishing a group for the crimes of individuals, and it's illegal under the Geneva Convention. Palestinians are trying to make the case in the foreign press that curfew, even though it's mostly nonviolent, is still a crime, punishing all of them for the actions of suicide bombers.
这个词组“集体惩罚”，是我采访的每一个巴勒斯坦人都提到的。我以为这只是一个流行的描述。直到我回来后才知道，“集体惩罚”是联合国使用的一个法律术语。它意味着为一个人的罪行惩罚一群人，根据《日内瓦公约》这是非法的。巴勒斯坦人正试图在外媒中证明，宵禁尽管大多是非暴力的，但仍然是一种犯罪，是对他们所有人因自杀式炸弹袭击者的行为而进行的惩罚。
Before I came to Ramallah, I pictured a bombed-out place with crude buildings and occasional gunfire in the streets. But it's not like that at all. It's a middle-class city with cafes, and car dealerships, and women in tight shirts, and signs in English for ice cream and internet service.
在我来到拉马拉之前，我脑海中的景象是一个被炸毁的地方，有简陋的建筑和街头时断时续的枪声。但完全不是那样。这是一个中产阶级的城市，有咖啡馆、汽车经销商，穿着紧身衬衫的女性，以及用英语写的冰淇淋店和互联网服务的招牌。
Now Ramallah's 40,000 residents are trapped in their homes and offices, waiting. Curfew is lifted arbitrarily, without notice, and reimposed a few hours later, also without notice. Days go by when it's not lifted at all.
现在，拉马拉的4万名居民被困在他们的家和办公室里，等待着。宵禁被随意取消，没有通知，几小时后又被重新实施，同样也没有通知。有时一连几天都不取消。
Cooped up, not knowing when they'll be let out, people get on each other's nerves. Adults bicker. Kids get restless and cranky.
被关在里面，不知道什么时候会被放出来，人们开始互相厌烦。大人们吵架。孩子们变得焦躁易怒。
Yeah. Sometimes I feel like it's just too much to survive it here. I miss to see movies. I miss to go for dinner with my friends, with my wife, to [UNINTELLIGIBLE], to see theater, I miss, you know, like just to walk in the park, and to go have a beer in bars and coffee shops. I love coffee shops. To go in and read. And I miss every detail for me. But then I think, my place is here.
是的。有时我觉得在这里生活简直太难了。我想念看电影。我想念和朋友们、和我的妻子出去吃饭，去[听不清]，去剧院，我怀念，你知道，就像去公园散步，去酒吧和咖啡店喝啤酒。我爱咖啡店。进去读书。我怀念每一个细节。但后来我想，我的位置在这里。
I think there's a law that every story about Palestinian has to include a scene at a checkpoint, usually with a woman crying and a 15-year-old kid who says at the end, if this keeps up, I might become a suicide bomber, too. We're not going to do that scene.
我认为有一条不成文的规定，即每个关于巴勒斯坦人的报道都必须包含一个检查站的场景，通常是一个哭泣的女人和一个15岁的孩子在最后说，如果这种情况持续下去，我也可能会成为自杀式炸弹袭击者。我们不会拍那个场景。
Though it is true that lots of Palestinians would like to see the end of Israel. A poll this June said that 51% of Palestinians believe the goal of the current intifada is to liberate all of historic Palestine. Meaning not just the West Bank and Gaza, but all of Israel. That same poll showed 68% of Palestinians support suicide bombings. Back during the peace process, support for suicide bombings was around 20%.
尽管确实有很多巴勒斯坦人希望看到以色列的终结。今年六月的一项民意调查显示，51%的巴勒斯坦人认为当前的起义目标是解放整个历史上的巴勒斯坦。这意味着不仅仅是西岸和加沙，而是整个以色列。同一项民意调查显示，68%的巴勒斯坦人支持自杀式炸弹袭击。在和平进程期间，对自杀式炸弹袭击的支持率约为20%。
Most of us watching this conflict from the United States want to believe that moderate Palestinian voices are out there. US policy is banking on it. So we decided to go out and find those people.
我们大多数从美国观看这场冲突的人都愿意相信，温和的巴勒斯坦声音是存在的。美国政策正押注于此。所以我们决定走出去寻找这些人。
I should say I'm very disappointed because there's no sound. This is a construction site. We shouldn't be able to talk and hear each other right now.
我应该说我很失望，因为没有声音。这是一个建筑工地。我们现在不应该能交谈并听到对方的声音。
Sam Bahour is a Palestinian-American who is building the largest shopping center in the West Bank, a $10 million project that's just about finished. But for weeks, almost no workers have been able to get to the site. Sam is trying not to dwell on that.
萨姆·巴胡尔（Sam Bahour）是一位巴勒斯坦裔美国人，他正在西岸建造最大的购物中心，这是一个价值1000万美元的项目，即将完工。但几周来，几乎没有任何工人能到达现场。萨姆正努力不去想这些。
This is the main entrance to the building. People would walk into here. And to the left, they have the option of going up the escalator and going to the first floor of the building, or walking into the lobby towards the panoramic elevator, or they would walk straight ahead into our supermarket that we will run and operate, or they can walk into the right, which will be a fast food restaurant.
这是建筑物的主入口。人们会从这里走进去。向左，他们可以选择乘坐自动扶梯到达建筑物的一楼，或者走向大厅前往全景电梯，或者他们可以直接走向我们将经营和运营的超市，或者他们可以向右走进一家快餐店。
This building is just like Sam-- big and ambitious. When the front of the building is put on-- and here's a sign of confidence in a city occupied by an army-- it's going to be a giant wall of glass, two stories high, arched.
这座建筑就像萨姆本人一样——宏大而充满雄心。当建筑物的前面安装好时——这是一个在被军队占领的城市中的信心标志——那将是一面两层楼高、呈拱形的巨大玻璃墙。
Sam grew up in Youngstown, Ohio, and came to the West Bank with his family for the first time when he was 10 years old. He returned every summer after that, taught himself Arabic, was president of the Palestinian Students Group in college. He was always looking for a way to move to the West Bank. He finally did in 1995 at the start of the Oslo peace process. He believes in two states-- one Israeli, one Palestinian, side by side.
萨姆在俄亥俄州的扬斯敦长大，10岁时第一次随家人来到西岸。之后他每年夏天都回来，自学了阿拉伯语，在大学里担任巴勒斯坦学生会主席。他一直想方设法搬到西岸。他最终在1995年奥斯陆和平进程开始时做到了。他相信“两国方案”——以色列和巴勒斯坦并肩存在。
For the last three years, he's been overseeing the construction of this building. With the recent siege, of course, that's become a little complicated. This actually created an unusual business problem for Sam.
过去三年里，他一直监督这座建筑的施工。当然，随着最近的围困，事情变得有点复杂了。这实际上给萨姆带来了一个不同寻常的商业问题。
What you find is people who are coming to try to rent now, because they know that they'll be able to get a better deal.
你发现有些人现在来试着租房，因为他们知道他们能谈到一个更好的价格。
Prospective tenants are angling for a better deal on the rent, because as one guy pointed out, there are tanks in the streets, and no one knows what disaster is going to come next.
潜在的租户正试图压低租金，因为正如一个人指出的那样，街上有坦克，谁也不知道接下来会发生什么灾难。
I mean, I was telling him that this is going to be the hottest spot in Ramallah, and he was saying that it's too close to the tanks that are next to-- about half a kilometer from us. So it's up to us now to just delay as much as possible until we're able to negotiate and better leverage our excellent building.
我是说，我告诉他这将是拉马拉最热门的地方，而他说它离坦克太近了——离我们大约半公里。所以现在取决于我们尽可能推迟，直到我们能够协商并更好地利用我们出色的建筑。
Sam estimates he's only two months of solid work away from finishing the building. He speaks confidently as we walk around the scaffolding, boxes of tile and light fixtures, and wooden pallets. But in his hand, he's working a set of worry beads.
萨姆估计距离完成这座建筑只需要两个月的踏实工作。当我们走在脚手架、瓷砖箱、灯具和木托盘之间时，他自信地谈着。但他手里正把玩着一串担忧念珠。
We go down to his office in the basement of the building and one of his staff brings us coffee. Wherever you go in the West Bank, people are going to bring you coffee, usually in these little cups on a tray. I don't drink coffee, and it took me an embarrassingly long time to realize that I should just take it when it's offered and have a polite sip. I take my sip, and Sam tells me how he moved here to help create the first Palestinian-owned private phone company in the West Bank and Gaza, and why, after moving halfway around the world and throwing his heart and soul into it, he quit.
我们下到位于大楼地下室的办公室，他的一名员工给我们端来了咖啡。无论你在西岸去哪里，人们都会给你端来咖啡，通常是用托盘上的小杯子装着。我不喝咖啡，但我花了尴尬的长一段时间才意识到，当它被提供时，我应该直接接受并礼貌地啜饮。我喝了一口，萨姆告诉我，他搬到这里是为了帮助创建西岸和加沙地带第一家巴勒斯坦人拥有的私营电话公司，以及为什么在搬到世界另一端并将心血投入其中后，他却辞职了。
I resigned after seeing that the Palestinian Authority was dealing with this company, in my terms, as a little heavy-handed. So like what would they do that was heavy-handed? Well, one thing that happened after I got the company, if I can mention it, is they, for example, moved the entire cellular business into a separate subsidiary. Without shareholder knowledge, without shareholder approval. And to me, this was not creating confidence.
在看到巴勒斯坦权力机构以我看来比较强硬的方式处理这家公司后，我辞职了。那么他们做了什么强硬的事情呢？好吧，在我接管公司后发生的一件事，如果我可以提到的话，是他们，例如，将整个移动业务拆分成了独立的子公司。在没有股东知情、没有股东批准的情况下。对我来说，这并没有建立起信心。
When he says "this was not creating confidence," Sam is way underplaying what happened. Which is that the bigwigs at his company, with the help of the Palestinian Authority, looted the company so they could make a pile of money, leaving smaller shareholders in the dust. They did this by splitting off the most lucrative part of the company secretly and out of the blue, and putting it into a separate company, whose only shareholders were the bigwigs and the Palestinian Authority. The Authority did this, Sam says, at the same time that it was crossing its heart in front of the UN, saying it was giving up its private investments so Palestinians would be able to trust that their leaders were more focused on public service than on making a buck.
当他说“这并没有建立起信心”时，萨姆是在极度淡化所发生的事情。事实是，他公司的那些大人物，在巴勒斯坦权力机构的帮助下，洗劫了这家公司以中饱私囊，让小股东一无所有。他们通过秘密且突然地将公司最赚钱的部分拆分出去，放入一家独立的公司，而这家新公司的唯一股东就是那些大人物和巴勒斯坦权力机构。萨姆说，权力机构在当着联合国宣誓自己正在放弃私人投资，以便巴勒斯坦人能够相信他们的领导人更专注于公共服务而非赚钱的同时，做了这些事。
But even though Sam was incensed to the point of quitting by the maneuvers of the Palestinian Authority, he describes the experience in the most charitable way possible.
但即使萨姆因巴勒斯坦权力机构的操作而愤怒到辞职，他还是以尽可能宽容的方式描述了这次经历。
It's not something that's out of the ordinary. Most third-world countries that privatize a sector have a hard time removing the government's role in that sector. Anywhere in the world. I mean, in Jordan as well.
这并不反常。大多数将某个行业私有化的第三世界国家都很难消除政府在其中的作用。世界上任何地方都是如此。我是说，在约旦也是这样。
The Palestinian community has been led, since the Oslo accords, by an institution that never had experience or training on state-building. Like the majority of the citizens of the world never dealt in building a state. Neither have we. They had experience and training on resisting Israel's occupation. So when they were put into the chair of having to do both, I think that they were not able to deal with the latter. And that was frustrating.
自《奥斯陆协议》签署以来，巴勒斯坦社区一直由一个从未有过国家建设经验或培训的机构领导。就像世界上大多数国家的公民从未处理过建设国家一样。我们也没有。他们拥有的是对抗以色列占领的经验和训练。所以当他们被置于必须两者兼顾的位置时，我认为他们无法处理后者。这令人沮丧。
Having said that, I'm one of the maybe few Palestinians who actually read Oslo, every part of Oslo, before I came. So when I came, I knew that there was a tremendous amount of complication built into the framework that was coming to live in. Putting above that the continuation of Israeli aggressions, whether it's the expansion of settlements and creation of new settlements, and constraining our population's movement, which required resistance. I tend to understand why this set of leadership was not able to do both tasks at the same time.
话虽如此，我可能是少数几个在来到这里之前真正读过奥斯陆协议（每一部分）的巴勒斯坦人之一。所以当我来的时候，我就知道我即将居住的框架中构建了大量的复杂性。再加上以色列持续的侵略，无论是定居点的扩张和新定居点的建立，以及限制我们人口的流动，这需要抵抗。我倾向于理解为什么这届领导层无法同时完成这两项任务。
There's an energy about Sam that I saw in few other Palestinians I talked to, that I've seen in few people, period. A cheerful relentlessness. Things that would sap other people's strength and will-- corruption, curfew, a tank outside his house for days-- seemed only to inconvenience him. Bad news is just additional information.
萨姆身上有一种我在其他巴勒斯坦人身上很少见到的活力，事实上我在极少数人身上才看到过。一种快乐的不屈不挠。那些会耗尽其他人力量和意志的事情——腐败、宵禁、在他家门口停了数日的坦克——似乎只是对他造成了不便。坏消息只是额外的信息。
[CAR ENGINE STARTING]
[汽车启动声]
Abruptly we have to leave. Curfew is being reimposed in ten minutes, an hour earlier than anyone had expected. As Sam is driving us through the city, cars are doing crazy moves to get home faster. U-turns in the middle of the street, signaling to each other who should go first with little honks, because the traffic lights are all destroyed and the streets in some places are such a chewed-up mess that people have to go around the chunks of concrete, or go over them very slowly so they don't break an axle.
我们必须突然离开。宵禁将在十分钟内重新实施，比任何人预期的都要早一个小时。当萨姆开车带我们穿过城市时，汽车都在疯狂移动以更快回家。在街道中间掉头，用小喇叭向对方示意谁该先行，因为交通灯全部被破坏，有些地方的街道一片狼藉，人们必须绕过混凝土块，或者非常缓慢地越过它们，以免弄坏车轴。
All of a sudden, two Israeli jeeps with loudspeakers on them are heading toward us. One on our side of the street, going against traffic, and another one on the other side.
突然，两辆装有扬声器的以色列吉普车朝我们驶来。一辆在我们这一侧的街道上逆向行驶，另一辆在另一侧。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
They will shoot. They will shoot if you don't abide by the curfew right now, they're going to shoot. That's what he's saying in Arabic.
他们会开枪的。如果你现在不遵守宵禁，他们会开枪的。这就是他用阿拉伯语所说的。
As we drive by, my adrenaline floods, and I think, we could die here, right here in Sam's olive green Hyundai.
当我们开车经过时，我的肾上腺素激增，我想，我们可能会死在这里，就在萨姆那辆橄榄绿色的现代车里。
If Israelis walk through their lives now, thinking, is this the cafe where I'll get blown up? How about this? This bus? Is it OK, or should I just walk? This moment in Ramallah, with curfew coming down, may be the Palestinian equivalent to that feeling. What ordinary activity will I be doing when I'm killed?
如果以色列人现在走过他们的生活，想着，这是我会遭到爆炸袭击的咖啡馆吗？那这个呢？这辆公共汽车？还可以，还是我该走路？拉马拉此时此刻，随着宵禁降临，可能相当于巴勒斯坦人那种感觉。当我被杀的时候，我会在做哪种普通的活动呢？
There's no time to talk about it. Sam can't take me all the way to the checkpoint. He apologizes. He has to get home. He flags me a taxi and speeds off.
没时间谈论它了。萨姆不能送我全程到检查站。他道歉说。他必须回家。他帮我拦了一辆出租车，然后飞驰而去。
Act Two. Here and There in the Land of Israel.
第二幕：以色列土地上的此地与彼方。
I traveled through Israel with Adam Davidson, a regular contributor to our show, who is half-Israeli. Growing up, he'd visit Israel every summer. He speaks Hebrew. He's been 19 times. And to get a sense of what it's like these days for Israelis, how things have changed recently with the end of the peace process, we talked to strangers and to people who Adam is known for years.
我和我们的节目常驻撰稿人亚当·戴维森（Adam Davidson）一起走访了以色列，他是半个以色列人。成长过程中，他每年夏天都会去以色列。他会说希伯来语。他已经去过19次了。为了了解以色列人如今的生活状况，以及随着和平进程的结束，情况最近发生了什么变化，我们采访了陌生人，也采访了亚当认识多年的人。
And driving from place to place, we ended up talking a lot about his grandmother, who moved to Palestine in the '30s, was part of that pioneer generation that created the state.
在开车往返于各地时，我们谈论了很多关于他祖母的事，她在30年代搬到了巴勒斯坦，是那一代创建国家的先驱者之一。
My grandmother was an old-school Zionist, and when I was a teenager, that seemed like the greatest thing in the world to be. She told me being a Zionist been having a grand dream and putting that above petty daily concerns. It meant redeeming not only the Jewish people, but the entire world, by becoming the planet's first truly enlightened nation. She described people back in the '30s and '40s who worked on farms, or they built banks and schools, and put everything they had into this collective dream of a proud new state.
我的祖母是一位老派的犹太复国主义者，当我十几岁时，那似乎是世界上最伟大的事情。她告诉我，成为一名犹太复国主义者意味着拥有一个宏伟的梦想，并将这个梦想置于琐碎的日常担忧之上。这意味着不仅要拯救犹太人民，还要通过成为地球上第一个真正开明的国家来拯救整个世界。她描述了30年代和40年代在农场工作、或者建造银行和学校的人们，并将他们拥有的一切投入到这个骄傲的新国家的集体梦想中。
We just spent two weeks in Israel, and as you might expect, we could not find a single person who still lives that way. Take Adam's best friend in Israel, Liat. She and her friends are pretty typical of people who live in Tel Aviv.
我们刚在以色列待了两周，正如你所预料的那样，我们找不到一个仍然那样生活的人。看看亚当在以色列最好的朋友利亚特（Liat）。她和她的朋友们是非常典型的生活在特拉维夫的人。
Ira and I go out with Liat and some of her friends one night. They agree to speak English for our microphones.
艾拉和我一天晚上和利亚特以及她的一些朋友出去。她们同意为了我们的麦克风用英语交谈。
It is an utterly familiar kind of evening. Liat's boyfriend is a musician, and he tells me about his home recording setup. Everyone chats about their vacations. Ayelah tries to convince Liat, for the hundredth time, to dump her cosmetologist, Klara, whom Ayelah used to go to herself.
这是一个非常熟悉的夜晚。利亚特的男朋友是个音乐家，他向我讲述了他的家庭录音设置。大家聊着她们的假期。阿耶拉（Ayelah）第一百次试图说服利亚特甩掉她的美容师克拉拉（Klara），阿耶拉自己以前也去那里。
She made me feel bad! I told her, listen. I don't want to pay you more. I don't care if I neglect my face.
她让我感觉很糟糕！我告诉她，听着。我不想付你更多钱了。我不在乎我的脸是否疏于打理。
So are you going to break up with her?
所以你要和她分手吗？
I don't know yet.
我还没决定。
It's difficult for her! It's difficult.
这对她来说很难！真的很难。
I hear them every week, they talk about that, that Klara. And they always say, yeah, we're going to leave her, we're going to leave her. That's never happened.
我每周都听她们说，她们谈论那个克拉拉。她们总是说，是的，我们要离开她，我们要离开她。这从未发生过。
I manage.
我能应付。
They want more than anything for Israel to be just another boring country like Norway or Belgium. My grandmother would think this was a repudiation of everything she ever believed in, though she would have been very polite about it.
她们最希望以色列能成为像挪威或比利时那样平庸的国家。我祖母会认为这是对她所信仰的一切的背弃，尽管她会对此非常有礼貌。
Of course all these people know that they are in a country at war. When you live here, you split yourself in two. You have knowledge of violence, and you decide at some level that it is not going to touch your life. Even when the conflict strikes close to home. For instance, a few weeks ago, Liat and her boyfriend Afir were about to leave for a movie when a bomb went off a block away.
当然，所有这些人都知道他们身处一个战争国家。当你住在这里，你把自己分成两半。你清楚存在暴力，并且你在某种程度上决定它不会触及你的生活。即使冲突就在家门口发生。例如，几周前，利亚特和她的男朋友阿菲尔（Afir）正要出门去看电影，一颗炸弹就在一个街区外爆炸了。
We heard an explosion, and they said on the news that it happened in Biyalik Coffee Shop, which is a place that I usually sit with my friends. I started shaking, I think, for a few minutes, and then I was very afraid. I felt like something crawled into my house.
我们听到了爆炸声，新闻里说它发生在比亚利克（Biyalik）咖啡馆，那是我通常和朋友坐的地方。我想我开始颤抖了，几分钟，然后我非常害怕。我感觉好像有什么东西爬进了我的房子。
I happened to call Liat right after that happened, and she told me that she completely came apart. She was crying and she couldn't breathe and she fell to the floor. And then the news reported that the explosion hadn't been at Biyalik Coffee Shop, but at the cafe directly next door, a place Liat and her friends don't go to.
在那件事发生后，我刚好给利亚特打了电话，她告诉我她彻底崩溃了。她在哭，无法呼吸，倒在了地板上。后来新闻报道说爆炸不是发生在比亚利克咖啡馆，而是就在隔壁的咖啡馆，一个利亚特和她朋友不去的地方。
And when it just moved two meters aside, I felt, OK. They still missed me. They still don't blow up places that I like to go to. I'm safe, in a way.
当它只是偏离了两米时，我感觉，好吧。他们还是错过了我。他们还是没有炸掉我喜欢去的地方。在某种程度上，我是安全的。
But it's stupid. When I tell you this, I see it's stupid. In a way, you try to find anything you can rely on, just to give yourself any kind of security, because you want to live your life.
但这很愚蠢。当我告诉你这些时，我看出它很愚蠢。在某种程度上，你试图寻找任何你可以依靠的东西，只为了给自己任何一点安全感，因为你想继续你的生活。
What's happened since my grandmother's time is that more and more Israelis just want to live their lives. This is a huge change. And to understand Israel today, you have to understand this change.
自祖母时代以来所发生的变化是，越来越多的以色列人只想过好自己的生活。这是一个巨大的变化。要了解今天的以色列，你必须理解这个变化。
Back in the '60s when pollsters asked Israelis about their hopes for themselves and for the state, most people said that their personal lives were very restricted, but they had huge hopes for the state of Israel. It was doing great.
回想60年代，当民意调查员问以色列人对他们自己和国家的希望时，大多数人说他们个人的生活非常受限，但他们对以色列国寄予厚望。它做得很好。
Today it's the exact reverse.
今天恰恰相反。
This is Asher Arian, a pollster at the Israel Democracy Institute.
这是以色列民主研究所的民意调查员阿舍·阿里安（Asher Arian）。
The exact reverse. The state is in bad shape. Personally, however, I'm doing all right. So this is a measure of where are your hopes, where are your dreams? And the dreams are clearly in personal achievement. The state is no longer the vehicle with which you feel good about yourself or the future.
恰恰相反。国家状况糟糕。然而，就个人而言，我过得还行。所以这是一种衡量标准：你的希望在哪里？你的梦想在哪里？梦想显然在于个人成就。国家不再是你对自己或未来感到良好的工具。
Most Israelis over 30 can tick off the reasons this changed. American consumerism swept through Israel just like it swept through every other country on earth, and Israel started doing things that seemed less noble and heroic. There was the 1973 war, which Israel nearly lost because of government bungling. There was the invasion of Lebanon, which turned into a kind of protracted Vietnam for them, which spanned two decades. And for some people, though definitely not all, there was the occupation of the West Bank and Gaza, which began in 1967. Even to Israelis, Israel seemed less heroic.
大多数30岁以上的以色列人可以列出发生这种变化的原因。美国消费主义像席卷全球其他所有国家一样席卷了以色列，以色列开始做一些看起来不那么高尚和英勇的事情。有1973年的战争，因为政府的拙劣管理，以色列几乎输掉了战争。有对黎巴嫩的入侵，这对他们来说变成了一场持续两十年的“越南战争”。对一些人来说，虽然绝对不是所有人，还有自1967年开始的对西岸和加沙的占领。即使对以色列人来说，以色列看起来也不那么英勇了。
Politics, which used to be a source of a sense of meaning and coherence for us, so long as we felt that we were morally in the right-- were just dragged from under our feet.
政治，过去是我们意义和连贯感的来源，只要我们觉得自己在道德上是正确的——就被从我们脚下拖走了。
In his book The Hunched Over Generation, a young writer named Gadi Taub argued that this was why he and other people who grew up after the 1967 war turned to their private lives. Because politics no longer gave them a feeling that they were part of a great, noble mission.
在他名为《佝偻的一代》（The Hunched Over Generation）的书中，年轻作家加迪·陶布（Gadi Taub）指出，这就是为什么他和1967年战争后长大的人转向私生活的原因。因为政治不再给予他们一种属于伟大、高尚使命的感觉。
What happened is that a whole generation had to turn a blind eye to politics. And so we sort of built a shield, saying, politics is something that happens over there. We are going to, you know, have earrings and pierce our belly buttons and have tattoos and just ignore politics altogether.
发生的情况是，整整一代人不得不对政治视而不见。所以我们建立了一层盾牌，说，政治是发生在“那边”的事情。我们要，你知道，戴耳环，穿肚脐环，纹身，完全忽略政治。
Listen, I have to stop you. I need something to eat. I have to eat--
听着，我得打断你。我需要吃点东西。我必须吃——
Yeah, can we order coffee and a lot of cakes?
是的，我们可以点咖啡和很多蛋糕吗？
Which brings us back to Liat and her friends. After dinner came dessert. Chocolate mousse, Bavarian tart, cheesecake.
这把我们带回了利亚特和她的朋友们。晚餐后是甜点。巧克力慕斯，巴伐利亚塔，芝士蛋糕。
If anything, the hopelessness and violence of the last few years since the peace process collapsed has pushed Liat and her friends even further away from politics.
如果说有什么影响的话，和平进程崩溃后过去几年的绝望和暴力，反而把利亚特和她的朋友们推得离政治更远了。
You read the newspaper? I don't read the newspaper every day.
你读报纸吗？我不是每天都读报纸。
It's like six months ago, the economic crisis and the bombs and everything-- me personally, I decided not to read the newspaper, not to read interviews, not watching TV, nothing. I go to the beach. I make meditation. I left my shrink, because when you go to shrink, you always talk about problems.
就像六个月前，经济危机、炸弹袭击以及所有的一切——我个人决定不读报纸，不读采访，不看电视，什么都不做。我去海滩。我做冥想。我离开了我的心理医生，因为当你去看心理医生时，你总是谈论问题。
We should be clear that when Iran says this, it means something different here than it does in the United States. At the same time that Israelis are withdrawing into their own lives, it's still just taken for granted that they have a special obligation to their country.
我们应该清楚，当“伊朗”说这些话时，它在这里的意思与在美国时不同。在以色列人退出自己的生活的同时，他们理所当然地认为自己对国家负有特殊义务。
For a month every year, Iran gives up his medication, puts on a uniform, and does reserve service, like most Israeli men. In fact, since the Second Intifada began, reservists have shown up in record numbers. Thousands showed up who weren't even called.
每年有一个月，伊朗放弃他的药物，穿上制服，服预备役，就像大多数以色列男人一样。事实上，自第二次起义开始以来，预备役军人以破纪录的人数出现。数千人甚至在没有被征召的情况下也出现了。
Back in America, we had heard about refuseniks, who won't fight in the West Bank and Gaza. But once we get to Israel, it became clear that they are very few-- in the hundreds. Still very marginal.
在美国，我们听说过拒绝服兵役者，他们拒绝在西岸和加沙作战。但一旦我们到达以色列，很明显他们很少——只有几百人。仍然非常边缘化。
This might sound crazy, given the news this week, but it's safer in Israel than you think. Several Israelis made a point of telling us that more people die in car accidents than die in suicide bombings or other attacks. And many people told us they try to ignore the danger and go about their lives.
这听起来可能很疯狂，考虑到本周的新闻，但在以色列比你想象的要安全。几位以色列人特意告诉我们，死于车祸的人比死于自杀式炸弹袭击或其他袭击的人多。很多人告诉我们，他们试图忽略危险，继续他们的生活。
Still, it's been 42 suicide bombings plus other fatal attacks for two years. Something every few days. And many people, especially parents, are more freaked out.
尽管如此，两年内还是发生了42起自杀式炸弹袭击加上其他致命袭击。每隔几天就会发生一次。许多人，特别是父母，更加惊慌。
It's also changed Israeli politics. Imagine if bombs went off in American cities every few days, what that would do to our politics.
它也改变了以色列政治。想象一下如果炸弹每隔几天在美国城市爆炸，那会对我们的政治造成什么影响。
A block east of my grandmother's 1930s apartment, we came across one of the oldest cafes in Tel Aviv.
在我祖母30年代公寓以东一个街区，我们偶然发现了一家特拉维夫最古老的咖啡馆。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], coffee, tamar.
[听不清]，咖啡，塔玛（Tamar）。
Tamal?
塔玛尔？
Tamar.
塔玛。
Tamar Cafe has been a left-wing hangout for more than 70 years, since my grandmother lived on the street. The Labor Party newspaper used to be next door.
塔玛咖啡馆作为左翼聚集地已经有70多年了，自打我祖母住在这条街上时就是如此。工党报纸以前就在隔壁。
Today the place is like a shrine to Yitzhak Rabin, prime minister of Israel during the start of the Oslo peace process, who was slain by a right-wing Israeli Jew. There are huge posters and paintings and drawings of him inside the cafe, and in the windows facing the street.
今天，这里就像是一个伊扎克·拉宾（Yitzhak Rabin）的神殿，他是奥斯陆和平进程开始时的以色列总理，被一名右翼以色列犹太人暗杀。咖啡馆内以及面向街道的窗户上都有他巨大的海报、绘画和素描。
And then that poster over there, lo what?
还有那边的海报，什么？
[SPEAKING HEBREW], we won't forget. But [SPEAKING HEBREW]--
[希伯来语]，我们不会忘记。但是[希伯来语]——
We won't forgive. Wow. That is intense. We won't forgive Netanyahu. That is amazing.
我们不会原谅。哇。那太强烈了。我们不会原谅内塔尼亚胡。这太惊人了。
Many left-wingers privately accuse Benjamin Netanyahu, who was then the leader of the right-wing Likud Party, of creating the angry anti-peace atmosphere that led to Rabin's assassination. But I've never seen a poster or anything so clearly and publicly blaming Netanyahu for Rabin's death.
许多左翼人士私下指责当时右翼利库德集团的领导人本杰明·内塔尼亚胡，称他制造了导致拉宾遇刺的愤怒的反和平气氛。但我从未见过像这样清晰且公开指责内塔尼亚胡导致拉宾死亡的海报或其他东西。
When we go inside, we're told that the place used to be filled, surprise, with left-wingers. Now the cafe is empty, except for three men in the corner playing backgammon, who say that we'd be hard-pressed to find even one leftist these days who would stand by his old peacenik believes.
当我们进去时，有人告诉我们，这个地方以前总是挤满了左翼人士。现在咖啡馆空荡荡的，只有角落里三个正在玩双陆棋的男人，他们说，如今我们要想找到一个坚持旧日和平主义信仰的左派人士都很难。
I was a member of the Labor Party for many years. Very big supporter of the peace process. And today, I'm more close to the most extreme right that to the left.
我多年来一直是工党成员。非常支持和平进程。而今天，我离极右翼比离左翼更近。
This is Sa'ar Arit, 36, a lawyer. With him is Yugal Saraf, a 58-year-old with lively eyes and a kind face, the perennial winner of backgammon games here.
这是36岁的律师萨尔·阿里特（Sa'ar Arit）。和他在一起的是58岁的尤格尔·萨拉夫（Yugal Saraf），他有着灵动的眼睛和一张善良的面孔，是这里双陆棋游戏的常胜将军。
One of the biggest ways the two years of intifada have changed Israel is now nearly everyone agrees on one important point. Everyone blames Arafat and the Palestinians for the collapse of peace process. There are nuances to this. Like leftists will remind you how Israel kept doing lousy things to ruin the peace process during the '90s, like building new Jewish settlements in the West Bank. And people on the right will say that Israel did nothing wrong, were simply prudent in the face of Palestinian violations of the Oslo accords.
两年起义改变以色列的最大方式之一，是现在几乎每个人都同意一个重要观点。大家都责怪阿拉法特和巴勒斯坦人导致了和平进程的崩溃。对此有细微差别。比如左派会提醒你，在90年代，以色列是如何不断做卑劣的事情来破坏和平进程的，比如在西岸建立新的犹太定居点。而右翼人士会说以色列没有做错任何事，只是在面对巴勒斯坦人违反《奥斯陆协议》时表现得审慎。
But everyone agrees on how the peace process ended. At Camp David in 2000, Arafat looked at the Israeli proposals, said no, and offered no counter-proposals. Then the bombings came.
但大家都同意和平进程是如何结束的。在2000年的戴维营，阿拉法特看了以色列的提议，说了“不”，并没有提供任何反建议。然后爆炸就开始了。
But as a result, Israelis have a kind of moral certitude that they are in the right. They're united on this in a way that perhaps they have never been united in their history. The attitude is, we tried everything. We were reasonable. We were generous. In the end, they didn't want peace.
但结果是，以色列人有一种道德上的确定性，认为自己是正确的。他们在历史上可能从未如此团结。态度是：我们尝试了一切。我们是合理的。我们是慷慨的。最终，他们不想要和平。
Even Yugal, who wants to give the Palestinians every benefit of the doubt, shakes his head when he talks about how the peace process ended.
即使是尤格尔，他本想给巴勒斯坦人每一个怀疑的好处，但在谈到和平进程如何结束时，他也摇了摇头。
And on that point, I blame the Palestinians or Arafat, which he was the leader, not to grab the opportunity. He could have said "no, but" something. But he said just "no." No means no.
关于这一点，我责怪巴勒斯坦人或者阿拉法特，他是领导者，没有抓住机会。他本可以说“不，但是……”之类的话。但他只是说了“不”。不就是不。
He just walked away.
他就那么走开了。
Walked away. So he brought this political situation to be hopeless.
走开了。所以他让这种政治局势变得绝望。
Today only 20% of Israelis believe that Palestinians want peace, according to polls. At the height of the Oslo peace process, two-thirds believed it.
根据民意调查，今天只有20%的以色列人认为巴勒斯坦人想要和平。在奥斯陆和平进程的高峰期，三分之二的人相信这一点。
The Palestinians doesn't want peace. They want to destroy Israel.
巴勒斯坦人不想和平。他们想摧毁以色列。
So you had some sympathy for the Palestinians before.
所以你以前对巴勒斯坦人还有些同情。
I have sympathy. I have sympathy today.
我有同情。今天我也有同情。
Everybody had sympathy.
每个人都曾有过同情。
They lost all their support within Israel. And that's their tragedy, because they won't get it back.
他们在以色列境内失去了所有的支持。这就是他们的悲剧，因为他们再也找不回这些支持了。
For a month every year, Sa'ar is an infantry man in the reserves, and he patrols in Ramallah, and Jenin, and Hebron, and other towns in the West Bank. He says he lost hope that the Palestinians want peace in October 2000, when two Israeli soldiers, older guys, reservists like him, got lost in Ramallah and were attacked by a mob in one of the most notorious incidents in the intifada.
每年有一个月，萨尔是预备役的步兵，他在西岸的拉马拉、杰宁、希伯伦和其他城镇巡逻。他说他在2000年10月失去了对巴勒斯坦人想要和平的希望，当时两名以色列士兵，年长些的人，像他一样的预备役，在拉马拉迷路，并遭到暴徒攻击，这是起义中最臭名昭著的事件之一。
And about 100 to 200 Palestinians tore them apart. And I felt that that was the breaking point for me. I thought that the Palestinians are animals.
大约100到200名巴勒斯坦人把他们撕碎了。我觉得那是我的崩溃点。我以为巴勒斯坦人是动物。
Ah. I want to say something. It is a bit simple-minded. But it's true, what he says in Ramallah.
啊。我想说点什么。这有点简单化了。但在拉马拉，他所说的确实是真的。
This is where we saw the photos of them holding their hands out the window, their bloody hands.
我们就是在那里看到了他们从窗户伸出双手的照片，他们血淋淋的手。
But the main question you should ask yourself is, how do people get that way? There's no people who are animals, and some are not animals. So they got this way by constantly being brainwashed that we are vicious and cruel and Satanic and God knows what. They get affected. And they could be good boys. This is not their nature. It's propaganda. It's brainwashing. This can be changed.
但你最应该问自己的问题是，人们是怎么变成那样的？没有哪种人天生是动物，而另一种不是。所以他们变成这样，是因为一直被洗脑，说我们是邪恶的、残忍的、撒旦般的，天知道还有什么。他们受到了影响。他们本可以成为好孩子。这不是他们的本性。这是宣传。是洗脑。这是可以改变的。
I mean, they're animals.
我是说，他们是动物。
But three years ago, you didn't believe that. They didn't become animals in three years.
但三年前，你不信那个。他们不是在三年内变成动物的。
Yeah. But what they did in the last year and a half broke everything.
是的。但在过去一年半里他们所做的事情破坏了一切。
Yugal points at a man sitting in the cafe's outdoor table.
尤格尔指着一个坐在咖啡馆室外桌子旁的人。
There is an Arab Israeli sitting there. You might want to talk to him.
那里坐着一个阿拉伯裔以色列人。你可能想和他谈谈。
He a friend of yours?
他是你的朋友吗？
Akram, yes.
阿克拉姆（Akram），是的。
You know him, too?
你也认识他？
Yeah, I know him.
是的，我认识他。
He an animal?
他是动物吗？
No. He's not an animal. I'll tell you why. He doesn't have the power.
不。他不是动物。我告诉你为什么。他没有那种力量。
Oh, he could be an animal if he had the power.
哦，如果他有力量，他可能会变成动物。
I'm telling you. If tomorrow the Arab countries will conquer Israel, it will change him in a minute.
我告诉你。如果明天阿拉伯国家征服了以色列，他一分钟内就会改变。
And I'm sorry to say this, but-- a leftist.
抱歉我得说这个，但是——一个左派。
Sure, I'm a leftist. That's the leftists of Israel today.
当然，我是个左派。这就是当今以色列的左派。
This is where the leftists come to. No longer advancing a peace process, they were arguing over whether the Arabs were born animals or were taught to be animals.
这就是左派到达的境地。不再推进和平进程，他们反而争论阿拉伯人是天生的动物还是被教导成动物的。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语]
This is my cousin David. He's standing in a hallway of the Knesset, the Israeli parliament, talking on one cell phone, when his other cell phone rings. He answers it.
这是我的表弟大卫。他站在以色列议会（Knesset）的走廊里，正在用一部手机通话，这时他的另一部手机响了。他接了起来。
David runs the office and political operations for a conservative member of parliament. And while the left might feel history has passed it by, David and his party, the Likud, are totally energized right now. They always opposed the peace process, and now it's dead. Their man Ariel Sharon is the prime minister, with the highest approval ratings in Israeli history. Finally, the army has struck decisively in the territories. And at last, Israelis agree that Arafat can't be trusted.
大卫负责一位保守派议员的办公室和政治运作，虽然左翼可能感到历史已经抛弃了他们，但大卫和他的政党——利库德集团，现在充满了活力。他们一直反对和平进程，现在和平进程死了。他们的人阿里埃勒·沙龙（Ariel Sharon）是总理，拥有以色列历史上最高的支持率。最终，军队在领土上进行了果断打击。最后，以色列人一致认为阿拉法特不可信。
This is all perfect for David, who got into politics in 1993 because he was alarmed at the newly-signed Oslo treaty.
这对大卫来说太完美了，他在1993年进入政坛是因为他对新签署的奥斯陆条约感到震惊。
You feel good, because you know that after ten years, what you said would happen, happened. Meaning that the whole Oslo accord will collapse, that the violence will return. And after ten years of the other side, the media, the public figures, and all of the left said that you don't know what you're talking about, and suddenly, the reality comes and you see that it is true-- that gives you a good feeling. Because you will know that you were right.
你感觉很好，因为你知道在十年之后，你所说会发生的事情确实发生了。这意味着整个奥斯陆协议将会崩溃，暴力将会回归。而在经历了十年另一方、媒体、公众人物和所有左派说你不知道你在说什么之后，突然之间，现实出现了，你看到它是真实的——这让你感觉很好。因为你会知道你是正确的。
We spent a day at the Knesset. Every time we tried to set up an interview with a member of a left wing party, we'd open the door, and there would be some older woman who looked like she'd been there since 1948, sitting alone, phones quiet.
我们在议会度过了一天。每次我们试图与左翼政党的成员安排采访，我们打开门，就会看到一些老妇人，看起来好像从1948年就待在那里一样，独自坐着，电话很安静。
Then we'd head back to the right, to David, where there would be phones ringing, people visiting, a gaggle of clean-cut members of the Likudnik Young Guard, happy and excited and busy. David is constantly pulling one after another up to our microphones and cheerfully announcing,
然后我们会回到右翼，回到大卫那里，那里电话响个不停，人们来访，一群干练的利库德青年卫队成员，快乐、兴奋且忙碌。大卫不断地把一个人接一个人带到我们的麦克风前，兴高采烈地宣布，
Here is somebody who would want an interview. He's very interesting. His name is Shimi ben David. He's assistant of the head of the Coalition, Mr. Ze'ev Boim.
这里有想接受采访的人。他非常有意思。他叫希米·本·大卫（Shimi ben David）。他是执政联盟负责人泽夫·博伊姆（Ze'ev Boim）先生的助手。
What's most surprising about watching them work is just how much of their attention, here in Israel's legislature, is focused on the United States. Of a staff of only four people, one of them is a specialist on the US Congress. On the desk of this member of Knesset, Yuval Steinitz, sits a business card from one US Congressman and a personal letter from another. On the day we visit, a delegation of a dozen US congressional aides drops by, as does former Republican presidential candidate, Gary Bauer. David orders Steinitz to put on a jacket for that one.
看着他们工作最令人惊讶的是，他们在以色列立法机构中，竟有如此多的精力集中在美国身上。在仅有四人的员工团队中，其中一人是美国国会专家。在这位议员尤瓦尔·斯泰尼茨（Yuval Steinitz）的桌子上，放着一张美国国会议员的名片和另一位议员的亲笔信。在我们访问的那天，十几名美国国会幕僚顺道拜访，前共和党总统候选人加里·鲍尔（Gary Bauer）也是。大卫命令斯泰尼茨为那个人穿上外套。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] jacket.
[听不清]外套。
Hi. How are you? Gary Bauer.
嗨。你好吗？加里·鲍尔。
Nice to meet you. Thank you for coming to us in such a difficult time. Very encouraging.
很高兴见到你。感谢你在如此困难的时期来到我们这里。非常鼓舞人心。
My pleasure. I've been a strong supporter of Israel, but my week here makes my feelings on behalf of Israel even stronger. So I can't wait to get back to Washington and--
不客气。我一直是以色列的坚定支持者，但我在这一周里的感受让我对以色列的支持更加坚定了。所以我迫不及待想回到华盛顿然后——
During their meeting, Steinitz urges Bauer to lobby Congress against advanced arms sales to Egypt and Syria.
在他们会晤期间，斯泰尼茨敦促鲍尔游说国会，反对向埃及和叙利亚出售先进武器。
This is more involvement in u s affairs than the average Knesset member has. And part of it is simple political ambition-- to get press attention, to get ahead in national politics here. It's helpful to be seen as a player in US-Israeli relations.
这比普通议员参与美国事务的程度要高。部分原因仅仅是政治抱负——为了获得媒体关注，为了在这里的全国政治中领先。被视为美以关系中的一个角色是有帮助的。
So it will be extremely important if you will succeed to encourage some of our, at least in friends, to visit us and [INAUDIBLE].
所以，如果你能成功鼓励我们的一些，至少是朋友，来访问我们并且[听不清]，那将极其重要。
If you want to understand why the right-wing and Ariel Sharon are so popular right now, and if you want to hear just how angry Israelis are, just visit a bus stop in Jerusalem. More bombs have exploded in Jerusalem than any other Israeli city.
如果你想了解为什么右翼和阿里埃勒·沙龙现在如此受欢迎，如果你想听听以色列人有多愤怒，只要去耶路撒冷的公共汽车站看看。在耶路撒冷爆炸的炸弹比任何其他以色列城市都多。
This 15-year-old in braces with pink rubber bands and one of the long skirts worn by the religious was waiting for a bus to the settlement her parents moved to from the US and was more or less typical of everyone we talked to at the bus stop.
这个戴着牙套、扎着粉色橡皮筋、穿着宗教人士所穿长裙的15岁女孩，正在等车去她父母从美国搬到的定居点，她或多或少代表了我们在车站交谈过的所有人。
First of all, I would kill Arafat. And we are not the ones who have to suffer. This is our country. We don't have to give it up for them. If they want to live with us, they have to accept our conditions. We don't have to be suckers, and like, get down on our knees for us. Because the fact is that before this whole peace agreement started, they were afraid of us. OK? They were afraid of us. No one threw stones. Everyone was afraid to walk in the street. And since this started, you know, we give them, like you know, there's a saying. You're give them one finger and they want the whole hand.
首先，我会杀了阿拉法特。我们不是那个必须受苦的人。这是我们的国家。我们不必为了他们放弃它。如果他们想和我们一起生活，他们必须接受我们的条件。我们不必做傻瓜，像那样跪在他们面前。因为事实是，在这个和平协议开始之前，他们害怕我们。好吗？他们怕我们。没有人投掷石块。每个人都害怕走在街上。自从这开始以来，你知道，我们给他们，就像你知道的那样，有一句谚语。你给他们一个手指，他们想要整个手。
Do you think that eventually there should be two states, or do you think Israel shouldn't give up the Territories?
你认为最终应该有两个国家，还是你认为以色列不应该放弃领土？
Israel shouldn't give up one inch of territory. This is our country. We fought for it. We won. That's it! You know? Stop being babies. Or do you want New York to be given back to the English or something? You know? It's stupid.
以色列不应该放弃一英寸的领土。这是我们的国家。我们为它战斗。我们赢了。就这样！你知道吗？别再像个孩子了。或者你想让纽约还给英国人什么的？你知道吗？这很愚蠢。
It's just that they hate us so badly, they want to do anything to kill us. Like the kids. They learn how to shoot guns. They learn in school how to hate Jews. I mean, my parents didn't bring me up that way. I wasn't brought up hate Arabs.
只是他们太恨我们了，他们想做任何事来杀了我们。就像孩子们。他们学习如何开枪。他们在学校学习如何恨犹太人。我是说，我父母没把我养成那样。我没被养成恨阿拉伯人。
But you do hate them.
但你确实恨他们。
I hate the people who want to kill me, yes. If there's one single person in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Ramallah, which I highly doubt there is. But if there's one single person there who is truly pro-Israel and pro-Jewish, then sure, I have nothing against them. But the fact is that the majority of all these people, they're murderers, you know?
我恨那些想杀我的人，是的。如果[听不清]和拉马拉有一个人是真正亲以色列和亲犹太人的，虽然我很怀疑有，但如果那里有一个人是那样，那么当然，我对他们没有意见。但事实是这些人中的大多数，他们是谋杀犯，你知道吗？
When we first arrived in Israel, an American TV cameraman told us that when you're in the Mideast, you constantly find yourself in social situations with people who are thoughtful, and funny, and incredibly gracious, and you hang out with them for hours-- the nicest people in the world-- and then they come out with some hateful comment that leaves you sort of stunned. This happens all the time, he says.
当我们刚到以色列时，一位美国摄像师告诉我们，当你在中东时，你经常会发现自己处于社交场合，与那些体贴、有趣且极其友善的人在一起，你和他们一起待上几个小时——世界上最善良的人——然后他们说出一些让你感到震惊的仇恨言论。他说，这种情况一直在发生。
At a party with Adam's Sephardic relatives, that is more or less what happened. One person after another tells us we have to kill the Arabs. We have to smack them down. The Arabs do not understand anything else. Then we ate cake and sang happy birthday to a one-year-old.
在亚当塞法迪亲戚的聚会上，或多或少就是这种情况。一个人接着一个人告诉我们必须杀死阿拉伯人。我们必须痛击他们。阿拉伯人不懂其他任何东西。然后我们吃蛋糕，为一岁生日的孩子唱生日快乐歌。
[SINGING IN HEBREW]
[希伯来语歌曲]
Surprisingly, the one person at the party who is at all sympathetic to the Palestinians is Egal, the father of the one-year-old birthday girl. He just returned from his reserve service in the West Bank in an elite combat unit. He was one of the Israeli soldiers you saw on TV, fighting at the Church of the Nativity in Bethlehem. He tells me he thinks Israel is to blame for the anger Palestinians feel against them.
令人惊讶的是，聚会上唯一一个对巴勒斯坦人有点同情心的人是伊格尔（Egal），那个一岁生日女孩的父亲。他刚从西岸的一个精英作战部队预备役中回来。他是你在电视上看到的那些在伯利恒耶稣诞生地教堂战斗的以色列士兵之一。他告诉我，他认为以色列对巴勒斯坦人感到的愤怒负有责任。
We didn't treat them well enough, so we drove them to the First Intifada. And that's led to the other events. I know the West Bank and Gaza Strip since I first came in in the First Intifada. And we know the ordinary civilians, they don't have high demands. They want to provide their family. That's all. To feel secure.
我们没有好好对待他们，所以我们把他们推向了第一次起义。这导致了其他事件。我从第一次起义时就了解西岸和加沙地带。我们了解普通平民，他们没有过高的要求。他们想要供养家庭。就是这样。感到安全。
I believe there will be someday a Palestinian country. I think it's going to be a democratic country. The first democratic Arab country.
我相信有一天会有一个巴勒斯坦国家。我认为它将是一个民主国家。第一个民主的阿拉伯国家。
In fact, every Israeli we talked to who served in the West Bank or Gaza tells us the same thing Egal says-- that their military service convinced them that Israel should eventually give up the territories. Even lots of hawks, right-wingers like Adam's cousin David, now say that Israel should someday get out of the territories. 80% of Israelis support some form of separation. 50% are still in favor of an independent Palestinian state. Ten years ago, this would have been seen as nearly traitorous by most Israelis. There was a fundamental change of opinion caused by the peace process. So at the same time that Israel has become so much more hawkish towards the Palestinians, it's as if the hawk has ingested a dove.
事实上，每一个我们在西岸或加沙服役过的以色列人都告诉我们和伊格尔一样的事情——他们的军事服役使他们相信以色列最终应该放弃领土。即使是许多鹰派，像亚当的表弟大卫这样的右翼人士，现在也说以色列应该有一天撤出领土。80%的以色列人支持某种形式的分离。50%的人仍然支持独立的巴勒斯坦国。十年前，这会被大多数以色列人视为几乎是叛国的。和平进程引起了舆论的根本转变。因此，在以色列对巴勒斯坦人变得更加强硬的同时，就好像鹰吃下了一只鸽子。
Still, nobody expects peace to arrive anytime soon. Even if a peace treaty were signed, only 22% of the country believes it would actually end the conflict. So now, instead of readying themselves for peace, Israelis are adjusting themselves to the lack of it.
尽管如此，没有人期望和平很快到来。即使签署了和平条约，也只有22%的国家相信它真的会结束冲突。所以现在，以色列人不再为和平做准备，而是让自己适应这种缺失。
Here's my friend Liat.
这是我的朋友利亚特。
Every year I say, oh my God. How I thought life could be different. And I see it's not. And I am losing something. I'm more mature, I'm more strong, maybe. But I'm losing something. Maybe I could keep it in a difference life.
每年我都说，天哪。我曾以为生活会是不同的。但我看到它不是。我正在失去一些东西。我更成熟了，我更坚强了，也许吧。但我正在失去一些东西。也许我可以在另一种生活中保留它。
Losing what?
失去什么？
I don't know. Something naive. Something with hope. In a way, I'm getting tough. Each year I'm tougher. And it's not always good for you to be tough.
我不知道。某种天真。某种带有希望的东西。在某种程度上，我变得强硬了。每年我都变得更强硬。而变得强硬对你来说并不总是好事。
Lots of people told us they didn't expect peace in their lifetime. Us Americans have to say, this is the main thing that we really did not understand before we got to Israel-- that Israelis are prepared for the idea that it will continue like this for years. They'd rather have peace, but they'll settle for what they have now. A war that produces fewer casualties than car accidents. A war where they dominate and control their enemy. A war, they'll tell you, that's unlike the wars of 1948 and '67 and '73 because it does not threaten Israel's existence.
许多人告诉我们，他们不期望在有生之年看到和平。我们美国人必须说，这是我们在来到以色列之前真的没有理解的主要事情——以色列人对这种状况将持续多年的想法已有准备。他们宁愿有和平，但他们会满足于现在所拥有的。一场造成的伤亡比车祸少得多的战争。一场他们主导并控制敌人的战争。他们会告诉你，这场战争与1948年、1967年和1973年的战争不同，因为它不威胁以色列的生存。
We came to Israel thinking what a lot of foreigners think-- that there's this great middle ground between the Israelis and the Palestinians, that the majority of reasonable people on both sides could work out a deal, and that the only problem is the small percentage of extremists on either side. After this trip, we don't feel so hopeful. The two sides are still far apart. The most generous Israeli offer is still short of the minimum demands of most Palestinians. And as the violence continues, the people in the middle are becoming more like the extremists.
我们带着许多外国人都有的想法来到以色列——认为在以色列人和巴勒斯坦人之间有巨大的中间地带，双方大多数理智的人都可以达成协议，而唯一的问题是双方的一小部分极端分子。在这次旅行之后，我们不再那么抱有希望了。双方仍然相距甚远。最慷慨的以色列提议仍然低于大多数巴勒斯坦人的最低要求。随着暴力的持续，中间地带的人们正变得越来越像极端分子。
Coming up. Palestinian moderates and Palestinian moderation. A guide for the perplexed in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将播出。巴勒斯坦温和派与巴勒斯坦温和主义。节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，为困惑者准备的指南，一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program about Israel and the West Bank continues. We've arrived at act three of our program.
这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们关于以色列和西岸的节目继续。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. What's a Moderate?
第三幕：什么是温和派？
I have to say, one of the few hopeful moments we had in Israel was in the cafe with all the pictures of Yitzhak Rabin. The older man that we interviewed, Yugal, was talking about how, in a way, Israelis have very short memories. "So much happens," he said, "that a bombing a few weeks ago can feel like years ago. As soon as the Palestinians have new leadership," he said, "as soon as there's some glimmer of hope, everyone will grab at it. Politics will change. You will see," he said. "People will grab at the smallest glimpse of hope."
我必须说，我们在以色列获得的极少数希望时刻之一，是在挂满伊扎克·拉宾照片的咖啡馆里。我们采访的那位年长男子尤格尔谈到，在某种程度上，以色列人的记忆力非常短。“发生的事情太多了，”他说，“几周前的爆炸袭击感觉就像几年前一样。只要巴勒斯坦人有了新的领导，”他说，“只要有一丝希望的微光，每个人都会抓住它。政治会改变。你会看到的，”他说。“人们会抓住最小的希望之光。”
Which brings us to our last story from Nancy Updike.
这把我们带到了南希·厄普代克的最后一个故事。
At the beginning of June, before President Bush's speech, Palestinians were asked the following question in a poll. Which Palestinian personality do you trust the most? Yasser Arafat was number one, with 25%. Next was the spiritual leader of Hamas, Sheik Ahmed Yassin, with 8%. And then there was 24% who said they didn't trust anybody. That "trust nobody" group was too small to be measured at the beginning of Oslo, but it's grown ever since, until finally it's caught up to Arafat.
六月初，布什总统讲话之前，巴勒斯坦人在一项民意调查中被问及以下问题：你最信任哪位巴勒斯坦人物？亚瑟·阿拉法特（Yasser Arafat）排名第一，占25%。其次是哈马斯的精神领袖谢赫·艾哈迈德·亚辛（Sheik Ahmed Yassin），占8%。然后有24%的人说他们不信任任何人。那个“不信任任何人”的群体在奥斯陆开始时太小而无法衡量，但此后一直在增长，直到最终赶上了阿拉法特。
In other words, there's a space opening in Palestinian politics. Arafat has always warned that any space he doesn't fill will be filled by Hamas. But what if there were a third choice? Not the corrupt autocracy of the Palestinian Authority and not the suicide bombing fundamentalism of Hamas?
换句话说，巴勒斯坦政治中正在打开一个空间。阿拉法特一直警告说，任何他不填补的空间都会被哈马斯填补。但如果还有第三个选择呢？不是巴勒斯坦权力机构的腐败独裁，也不是哈马斯的自杀式炸弹基本教义派？
Since I arrived, I'd been hearing a lot about a man named Mustafa Barghouti, a doctor who heads one of the biggest medical relief organizations in the occupied territories, and who's been speaking out a lot lately on political issues.
自从我到达后，我一直听到关于一个叫穆斯塔法·巴尔古提（Mustafa Barghouti）的人，他是一名医生，领导着被占领土上最大的医疗救援组织之一，最近经常就政治问题发表意见。
I went to Ramallah to meet him. I went with Rula Halawani, a Palestinian photojournalist who signed on to be my guide and translator. At the checkpoint, she asked people if they'd heard of Mr. Barghouti.
我去拉马拉见他。我和鲁拉·哈拉瓦尼（Rula Halawani）一起去，她是一位巴勒斯坦摄影记者，同意担任我的向导和翻译。在检查站，她问人们是否听说过巴尔古提先生。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Of course, everybody knows him. Who doesn't know him? [SPEAKING ARABIC]
当然，每个人都认识他。谁不认识他？[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
He's the best, he's just the best. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
他是最好的，他简直是最好的。[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
He's a very good guy. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
他是一个非常好的人。[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC] He's a good man. Very good man.
[阿拉伯语]他是一个好人。非常好的人。
Politically, Barghouti has two advantages that can also be disadvantages. First, he's been doing medical relief for over 20 years, and many people know him through that and love him for it. The downside is that many see him as a doctor, not a political figure. They don't even necessarily know what he believes in politically.
在政治上，巴尔古提有两个优势，也可能是劣势。首先，他已经做了20多年的医疗救援，许多人通过这个认识他并因此爱戴他。缺点是许多人把他视为一名医生，而不是政治人物。他们甚至不一定知道他在政治上信仰什么。
Second, his distant cousin is Marwan Barghouti, a popular leader in Arafat's Fatah Movement who's in an Israeli jail now, charged with ordering suicide bombings. So the Barghouti name is one that people know and respect, but sometimes people confuse Mustafa with Marwan, or simply don't see any difference between the two, even though Mustafa preaches nonviolence while Marwan is more of a Malcolm X figure-- by any means necessary.
其次，他的远房表弟是马尔万·巴尔古提（Marwan Barghouti），阿拉法特法塔赫运动中一位受欢迎的领导人，现在被关在以色列监狱里，被控下令进行自杀式炸弹袭击。所以“巴尔古提”这个名字是人们知道并尊重的，但有时人们会把穆斯塔法和马尔万搞混，或者干脆看不出两者之间有什么区别，尽管穆斯塔法宣扬非暴力，而马尔万更像是一个马尔科姆·X（Malcolm X）式的人物——不惜一切代价。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
All the Palestinians like Mustafa Barghouti and think he's a great guy. He does so much for the society. And also Marwan Barghouti. He's the same. The two of them.
所有的巴勒斯坦人都喜欢穆斯塔法·巴尔古提，认为他是个伟人。他为社会做了很多。还有马尔万·巴尔古提。他也是。他们两个。
Which one does he agree with more?
他更认同哪一个？
Which one--? [SPEAKING ARABIC]
哪一个——？[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Believe in every guy who's honest and is straight and works for the Palestinians.
相信每一个诚实、正直、为巴勒斯坦人工作的人。
Vitamin E, 600 milligrams.
维生素E，600毫克。
Mustafa Barghouti is on the phone when we get there. His organization, the Union of Palestinian Medical Relief Committees, gets medicine and basic care to people who can't make it to a hospital or clinic. They've been very busy under curfew.
穆斯塔法·巴尔古提在我们到达时正在打电话。他的组织，巴勒斯坦医疗救济委员会联盟，为那些无法去医院或诊所的人提供药物和基本护理。他们在宵禁下一直非常忙碌。
Barghouti is hard to keep up with. In one day he had two meetings, did five interviews, went to a demonstration, gave medicine to several people, and did more than one impromptu medical examination in the hallway on the way to his meetings.
巴尔古提让人很难跟上他的步伐。在一天之内，他参加了两次会议，做了五次采访，去了一次示威，给几个人发了药，并在去开会的走廊里做了不止一次即兴的医疗检查。
Which doctor saw her? This doctor. He doesn't know his name. And now he's showing the X-ray of the child.
哪个医生看了她？这个医生。他不知道他的名字。现在他正在展示孩子的X光片。
A father has stopped Barghouti in the hallway to show him his six-year-old daughter. She has terrible headaches, and she's had them for four months, he says. She cries a lot and sometimes she throws up. She's wearing a pink sweater and white sandals.
一位父亲在走廊里拦住了巴尔古提，让他看自己六岁的女儿。他说，她头痛得厉害，已经持续四个月了。她哭得很凶，有时还会呕吐。她穿着粉色的毛衣和白色的凉鞋。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
He told him, you must have this test for her. It's urgent.
他告诉他，你必须为她做这个检查。很紧急。
And he wrote down MRI, CT scan of the brain.
他写下了MRI，脑部CT扫描。
Yes.
是的。
Yasser Arafat, in his recent scrambling to seem like a reformer, offered Barghouti a ministry. Barghouti turned him down. He has something bigger in mind.
亚瑟·阿拉法特在最近试图让自己看起来像个改革者时，给巴尔古提提供了一个部长职位。巴尔古提拒绝了他。他有更大的计划。
Six weeks ago, Barghouti and a few other community leaders launched what they called the Palestinian National Initiative. That rather bland name conceals a radical proposition. They want to create the first new political movement among Palestinians since Hamas emerged in the late 1980s. The First Intifada brought Hamas. Barghouti is trying to make the second bring real democracy.
六周前，巴尔古提和其他几位社区领袖发起了所谓的“巴勒斯坦国家倡议”。那个相当平淡的名字掩盖了一个激进的提议。他们想要创建哈马斯在80年代末出现以来巴勒斯坦人中的第一个新政治运动。第一次起义带来了哈马斯。巴尔古提正试图让第二次起义带来真正的民主。
The National Initiative calls for immediate elections, run by somebody other than Arafat's election commission. Supervised by international observers, it calls for an end to suicide bombings and other attacks on Israeli civilians.
国家倡议呼吁立即举行选举，由阿拉法特的选举委员会以外的人管理。在国际观察员的监督下，它呼吁结束自杀式炸弹袭击和其他对以色列平民的攻击。
[CHANTING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语高呼]
Curfew's been lifted for a few hours, and Barghouti and some other representatives of nongovernmental organizations are staging a demonstration in Ramallah's main square. They're protesting curfews, closures, and the occupation. Maybe you can tell from how thin the chant is that there are only about 30 people at the demonstration, including Barghouti.
宵禁已取消几个小时，巴尔古提和其他一些非政府组织代表正在拉马拉中心广场进行示威。他们抗议宵禁、封锁和占领。也许你可以从口号声的稀疏看出示威活动只有约30人，包括巴尔古提。
Why do you think more people aren't joining the demonstration?
你认为为什么没有更多人参加示威？
Well, first of all, the timing is not very good. And as I told you, because many of them are busy. And also it needs better organization. But with time, this is our stand. This is like a beginning. It makes a position. It shows that civil society is against this oppression. It shows that there is nonviolent approach to struggle. And it will build up gradually. This gives people the impression that something can be done, and it is doable.
嗯，首先，时间不太好。正如我告诉你的，因为他们很多人都很忙。而且这需要更好的组织。但随着时间的推移，这就是我们的立场。这就像是一个开始。它确定了一个立场。它表明公民社会反对这种压迫。它表明有一种非暴力的方法来斗争。它会逐渐建立起来。这让人们产生了一种可以做点什么，而且这是可行的印象。
Something can be done other than suicide bombings?
除了自杀式炸弹袭击，还有别的事可以做吗？
Exactly. That there is a place, there is a space, and there is an effective nonviolence present, yes.
正是。有一个地方，有一个空间，并且有一种有效的非暴力存在，是的。
Barghouti stands in the middle of the demonstrators, dressed simply in dark gray pants and a blue shirt with white pinstripes. He wears glasses. He's almost 50 and his face has the lines of a person who squints a lot, smiles a lot, and worries a lot.
巴尔古提站在示威者中间，穿着朴素，深灰色裤子和带有白色细条纹的蓝色衬衫。他戴着眼镜。他快50岁了，脸上有着经常眯眼、经常微笑、经常担忧的人所特有的皱纹。
It's strange, but if you see him in a crowd of 30 people, even if he's not doing anything, you can tell he's the leader. He has that easy strength that makes people feel excited and relieved to see him. Oh, thank God he's here. He seems important. Too important, frankly, to be at an anemic rally in the middle of the day. He seems out of place.
很奇怪，但如果你在30人的人群中看到他，即使他什么都不做，你也能看出他是领导者。他有一种轻松的力量，让人们感到兴奋和宽慰。哦，谢天谢地他在那儿。他看起来很重要。坦白说，重要到不该在中午参加一场苍白的集会。他显得格格不入。
"Moderate" can mean a lot of things here. Among Palestinians, what it usually means is that they accept the premise of Oslo-- that someday there will be two states, side by side, with peace. And if you press these moderates-- and you don't have to press hard-- a lot of them will say, yeah, of course two states. And then in 20 or 30 years of peace, who knows? Maybe the balance of power will change. Maybe the two states will become one big democracy.
“温和”在这里可以意味着很多事情。在巴勒斯坦人中，它通常意味着他们接受奥斯陆的初衷——即有一天会有两个国家，并肩存在，享有和平。如果你向这些温和派施压——你不需要施压太紧——很多人会说，是的，当然是两国。然后经过20或30年的和平，谁知道呢？也许权力平衡会改变。也许两国会变成一个大的民主国家。
A democracy, as any Israeli would quickly point out, where Jews would be in the minority. It would be the end of the Jewish state.
正如任何以色列人会迅速指出的那样，在一个犹太人将成为少数的民主国家。那将是犹太国家的终结。
Here's Barghouti's position.
这是巴尔古提的立场。
Two states. International presence. A complete Israeli withdrawal from West Bank, Gaza Strip, and East Jerusalem. Allowing Palestinians to have a sovereign state that is demilitarized. I want to demilitarize before the Israelis. I don't want to see weapons in our country. We've seen enough weapons in our life.
两国。国际存在。以色列完全撤出西岸、加沙地带和东耶路撒冷。允许巴勒斯坦人拥有一个非军事化的主权国家。我想要在以色列人之前非军事化。我不想在我们的国家看到武器。我们这辈子见过的武器已经够多了。
That is a solution. That is a vision that is doable and achievable. And I even have a bigger vision I don't know if it would work, but it's a dream, maybe. I believe that one day, Jordan, Israel, and Palestine could be like a unified Benelux country.
这是一个解决方案。这是一个可行且可实现的愿景。我甚至有一个更大的愿景，我不知道它是否可行，但这可能是一个梦想。我相信有一天，约旦、以色列和巴勒斯坦可以像统一的“比荷卢”（Benelux）国家一样。
Benelux-- the loose federation of Belgium, the Netherlands, and Luxembourg.
比荷卢——比利时、荷兰和卢森堡的松散联盟。
The three countries, I mean, they need each other. They will have, the three together, bigger space. This will be the best solution of solving water problems. This will solve immediately the issue of refugees, because it will be free movement for everybody. And they will have a shared future and a shared vision.
这三个国家，我的意思是，他们需要彼此。这三个国家合在一起，会有更大的空间。这将是解决水问题的最佳方案。这将立即解决难民问题，因为每个人都可以自由流动。他们将拥有共享的未来和愿景。
If the Israelis wanted to view this Benelux scheme in a glass half full sort of way, they could see it as similar to a plan former Israeli Prime Minister Shimon Peres has floated in the past. On the other hand, they could choose to see it as a Trojan horse with the goal of eroding borders and flooding Israel with Palestinian refugees. A way of sneaking the destruction of Israel into the conversation rather than openly calling for it.
如果以色列人想以“半杯水”的心态看待这个比荷卢方案，他们可能会认为它类似于前以色列总理希蒙·佩雷斯（Shimon Peres）过去提出的计划。另一方面，他们可以选择将其视为一颗“特洛伊木马”，目标是侵蚀边界并用巴勒斯坦难民淹没以色列。这是一种将摧毁以色列的意图潜入对话，而不是公开呼吁的方式。
Barghouti is in a meeting, so Rula and I are hanging out the window at his office, watching people hurry home before curfew. We're reading graffiti on the buildings across the street.
巴尔古提在开会，所以鲁拉和我挂在他们办公室的窗户上，看着人们在宵禁前匆忙回家。我们正在读街对面建筑物上的涂鸦。
The graffiti says-- OK. Put your ten fingers on the button that fires the gun. I don't know what you call it.
涂鸦上写着——好吧。把你十个手指放在开火的按钮上。我不知道你们管它叫什么。
The trigger
扳机。
The trigger, yeah. Put your ten fingers on the trigger.
扳机，是的。把你的十个手指放在扳机上。
Hamas is more popular now than it's ever been. The latest polls show it running neck and neck with Arafat's Fatah movement. Both get around 25%. Hamas leaders are seen as incorruptible-- driven by commitment to Islam, not a desire for personal gain. Hamas also helps people rebuild homes that have been demolished by the Israelis, gives money to start small businesses, runs schools and youth centers. Hamas gained support for its suicide missions by making people's lives better.
哈马斯现在比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。最新的民意调查显示，它与阿拉法特的法塔赫运动不相上下。两者各占约25%。哈马斯领导人被视为不可腐蚀的——受伊斯兰教承诺的驱动，而不是对个人利益的渴望。哈马斯还帮助人们重建被以色列人拆毁的房屋，为创办小企业提供资金，经营学校和青少年中心。哈马斯通过改善人们的生活赢得了对其自杀式任务的支持。
Barghouti believes he can take on Hamas and win, because his strengths are Hamas' strengths. He and the network of nongovernmental aid organizations he's part of. He's on the ground, helping people, every day, with medical care and other social services.
巴尔古提相信他可以挑战哈马斯并获胜，因为他的优势正是哈马斯的优势。他和作为其中一员的非政府援助组织网络。他每天都在实地帮助人们，提供医疗护理和其他社会服务。
He's also seen as not corrupt, as clean. His medical relief organization is nonprofit, all-volunteer, and gets audited regularly. a computer technician I met told me, you can tell he's claimed by the car he drives. A 1989 Opel Cadet. Palestinian Authority ministers drive Mercedes and BMWs.
他还被视为没有腐败，是清廉的。他的医疗救援组织是非营利的、全志愿的，并且定期接受审计。我遇到的一位计算机技术员告诉我，你可以通过他开的车看出他是否清廉。一辆1989年的欧宝（Opel）Kadet。巴勒斯坦权力机构的部长们开的是奔驰和宝马。
His Achilles' heel with Hamas is that they're religious. He's secular.
他与哈马斯相比的“阿喀琉斯之踵”是他们是宗教性的。而他是世俗的。
He won't say whether he'll run for president or some other office in the January elections Arafat has promised. But Rula and I do a small survey anyway. At the checkpoint, we ask people who say they think Barghouti is a good man whether they would vote for him in an election. Their answers surprised us.
他不会说他是否会竞选总统或阿拉法特承诺的1月选举中的其他职位。但鲁拉和我还是做了一个小调查。在检查站，我们问那些认为巴尔古提是个好人的人，他们是否会在选举中投票给他。他们的回答让我们大吃一惊。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Of course. What does he think of Arafat?
当然。他怎么看阿拉法特？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Arafat is our father, Arafat is our symbol, and I would vote for Arafat if he runs for election again.
阿拉法特是我们的父亲，阿拉法特是我们的象征，如果他再次竞选，我会投票给阿拉法特。
If he was running and Mustafa Barghouti was running against him, who would he vote for?
如果他参选而穆斯塔法·巴尔古提与他对决，他会投票给谁？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Arafat.
阿拉法特。
Why?
为什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]?
[阿拉伯语]？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Nobody can do the job besides Yasser Arafat. Arafat is the symbol. He is the father of the Palestinian people.
除了亚瑟·阿拉法特，没有人能胜任这项工作。阿拉法特是象征。他是巴勒斯坦人民的父亲。
[SPEAKING ARABIC] Hamas?
[阿拉伯语]哈马斯？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
It's a good movement.
这是一个好的运动。
If it was a choice between a Hamas person and Mustafa Barghouti, who would he pick?
如果在哈马斯人士和穆斯塔法·巴尔古提之间选择，他会选谁？
OK. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
好的。[阿拉伯语]
Hamas.
哈马斯。
Hamas? Why? [SPEAKING ARABIC]
哈马斯？为什么？[阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Because they believe in our religion, and everything they do is based on our religion.
因为他们信仰我们的宗教，他们所做的一切都基于我们的宗教。
Barghouti ran for office before, in 1996, for a seat on the legislative council. He lost by a very narrow margin to Marwan Barghouti. The results were contested and widely seen as fixed.
巴尔古提以前竞选过公职，在1996年，竞选立法会的一个席位。他以微弱的劣势输给了马尔万·巴尔古提。选举结果受到质疑，并被广泛认为是作假的。
The time between now and January is an eternity, politically speaking. It's even possible that Arafat won't run. Almost anything can happen.
从现在到一月的时间，从政治上讲，是一个永恒。甚至有可能阿拉法特不会参选。几乎任何事情都有可能发生。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普代克。
Some of the music for our today was created for us by Stuart Rosenberg and Barb Wertico. Visit our website this week. Visit for links to some amazing journalism about Israel. www.thisamericanlife.org. You can also listen to our program for free there, or order a tape
我们今天的一些音乐是由斯图尔特·罗森伯格（Stuart Rosenberg）和巴布·沃蒂科（Barb Wertico）为我们创作的。本周访问我们的网站。访问获取关于以色列的一些精彩新闻报道的链接。www.thisamericanlife.org。你也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目，或订购磁带。
This American Life comes you from the city of Chicago, Richard M. Daley, mayor. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago.
《这就是美国生活》来自芝加哥市，市长理查德·M·戴利（Richard M. Daley）。《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我们节目的资金来自WBEZ芝加哥的听众。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wants to take this time to introduce you the man who will be hosting our show from now on--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他想借此机会向你介绍今后将主持我们节目的人——
He's the assistant of the head of the coalition, Mr. Ze'ev Boim.
他是执政联盟负责人泽夫·博伊姆先生的助手。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《这就是美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。